6h30 ce matin une poignée d'agriculteurs
du loir et cher ont investi la place de
la sous préfecture ne sont pas venus
seuls dans les bétaillères quelques
vaches des moutons et des volailles
objectif protester contre le projet de
nouveau zonage des régions défavorisées
avec ses sols pauvres le territoire de
l'asean qui en faisait partie depuis 40
ans risquent de ne plus bénéficier des
aides spécifiques
bah moi sur mon exploitation c'est un
manque à gagner puisque c'est de la pac
en moins c'est une aide compensatoire
qu'on a dans les zones défavorisées que
moi je ne toucherai plus et aujourd'hui
c'est lors de 8000 euros sachant
qu'aujourd'hui je me prélève 200 euros
par mois pour vivre
donc si demain j'ai pu c'est 8 millions
ça va être très compliqué pour mon
exploitation et pour ma famille à 8h30
une délégation est reçue par la
sous-préfète de romorantin
les agriculteurs n'ont qu'un seul but
demandez à la représentante de l'état de
décrocher un rendez vous avec matignon
les pourparlers auront duré une
demi-heure mais pas de rendez vous fixé
la pression monte d'un cran et la
première bétaillère et décrocher ils ont
jusqu'à 17h pour nous donner nous
trouver un rendez vous à matignon
sinon on va revenir alors la voilà au
monde d'un clic est beaucoup plus
nombreux et on va pas du tout rigoler à
17 heures donc nouveau rassemblement
devant la sous préfecture
les paysans prévenu la pression risque
de monter d'un cran